SAL: This is Sal again, and
this part four on the series
that we're doing at
Stanford Medical School,
with Doctor Connolly.
DR. CONNOLLY: All right
Sal, we're back here again.
This is now the
fourth of the slides.
And this would be
now the business
for why that segment
of colon was removed.
This is the colon cancer.
SAL: Wow, wow.
DR. CONNOLLY: And
so just to orient,
we'll go now to the drawing.
Which is, like you were
saying before, up here
this is the lumen.
SAL: Right.
DR. CONNOLLY: Up here.
Out here, that's the--
SAL: Lumen is the
inside of the colon.
DR. CONNOLLY: The inside.
That's the inside.
Out here, this is the
rest of your belly.
SAL: Right.
DR. CONNOLLY: Where
the bowel is all kind
of rotating around
in the abdomen.
And so--
SAL: Is there a word for
like intra-abdominal--
DR. CONNOLLY: Yeah, peritoneal.
SAL: Peritoneal, OK.
DR. CONNOLLY: The
peritoneal cavity
is where all the bowel loops are
kind of just moseying around.
And then what we
have here is, this
is an important
part, which is this
is the muscle that
allows peristalsis.
SAL: Yes, that's the peri-- I
learned that in high school.
That's the kind of moving,
the undulating motion
to the push stuff.
DR. CONNOLLY: Yep.
It'll go and it'll
sort of milk it along
in order for the
contents to move along.
So you can see, the muscle
looks all fine there.
That's how thick
it's supposed to be.
And it all looks fine over here.
SAL: Just on a scale,
what scale is this?
Like how thick is that muscle?
DR. CONNOLLY: So
we're now, once again,
our tiny little red blood cells
are those little dots there.
SAL: Right.
DR. CONNOLLY: So we're
talking about the thickness
here as a few millimeters.
SAL: That muscle is
about a few millimeters.
DR. CONNOLLY: Remember
back to this guy,
that was about six millimeters.
So that's about six--
SAL: OK, OK.
DR. CONNOLLY: Millimeters thick.
That's actually strong.
That's a very,
very strong muscle.
And you can kind of
see it goes up here,
it kind of comes
around here, but it's
looking like it's troubled
all along this area.
SAL: Yes.
And this stuff, all this stuff,
this once was probably a polyp,
and now it's turned into a
kind of this massive polyp?
DR. CONNOLLY: Yeah, so we
have the normal over here,
for the lining.
This is where it's
going dysplastic.
It's looking a
little bit bad there.
There's where it's
going dysplastic.
And so now what
happens is, you've
got these edges of dysplasia--
SAL: When people in the
medical field say plastic,
they're saying, that
word means tissue?
DR. CONNOLLY: Well plastic in
general, like plastic surgery,
or the plastics as far
as a material science,
means moldable.
SAL: I see.
DR. CONNOLLY: But it also
means you can grow with it,
and it can change shape.
SAL: Right.
So when you call something
plastic it's moldable tissue.
DR. CONNOLLY: It's
the shape change.
SAL: It's a shape change.
I see.
DR. CONNOLLY: And so the
shape changes were wrong.
SAL: I see.
DR. CONNOLLY: And
actually dysplasia
can refer to a cell, a tissue,
an organ, or an entire limb.
SAL: Oh, OK.
DR. CONNOLLY: So it just
means it grew wrong.
Or molded wrong.
So now this is where we
have the cell dysplasia.
This is all the bad stuff.
And it basically started
probably somewhere up there,
and is invading in all
of these directions.
SAL: This one cell
up there just started
dividing uncontrollably--
DR. CONNOLLY: That's right.
SAL: And it's descendants.
DR. CONNOLLY: It could
have started from one cell
being very bad.
It often though starts--
and I'm going to change now,
so we'll lose our art, and
so what I'm going to do
is change this-- that
it often starts, though,
from one of these.
Meaning maybe a cell went
bad right around there.
And now really is
starting to grow.
SAL: And when you say grow,
it's not just one cell,
it's all of its descendants.
DR. CONNOLLY: It's descendants.
And billions of
cells are growing.
Billions and billions
are growing downward
in order to now, in this case,
grow all the way through.
SAL: Wow.
DR. CONNOLLY: And so you can see
the scale is, it not only grew
a little bit, it went
right through the muscle.
So going back to this
guy here, this is now--
SAL: And there
are some, the body
does have things to fight this
off, but it was unsuccessful.
DR. CONNOLLY: Oh that's right.
And so there are
certain conditions
where if you decrease the immune
functions, you'll get cancer.
And so it's still argued
though whether it's
that your immune system is
decreased, you got a virus,
and then the virus
caused the cancer.
Or whether there's a
lot of surveillance
there to eliminate cancer.
SAL: And the whole notion that
viruses-- it's fascinating.
It's because viruses
are messing with our--
isn't a significant chunk of our
own DNA from ancient viruses?
DR. CONNOLLY: Yep.
And I think there's a couple
big categories is that viruses
can get into your DNA and
really screw up the DNA.
Like getting integrated into it.
But they also, like we said
before, can lead to irritation.
And then more cell growth
and have trouble there.
SAL: Makes sense, makes sense.
DR. CONNOLLY: So
now we're back here,
in which we're
looking at the cancer.
Which probably, like
you said, started here.
And is growing,
including spreading out
all the normal tissue around it.
SAL: Wow.
DR. CONNOLLY: And so we're
going to look now at the cells.
So zoom in.
Zoom time.
Hang on to your hat.
OK, so what we're going
to do is first-- probably
go into a lower power here--
is look at the edges of this.
So once again, we find normal.
And so this is even
not perfectly normal,
you can see it's a
little bit dividing
and a little bit irritated.
So this is irritated
along the edge.
SAL: Hyperplasia.
DR. CONNOLLY: Exactly.
SAL: I'm like, I'm
learning something.
DR. CONNOLLY: All right.
So then what we have now
is, as you go in deeper,
these are the areas
which are normal,
but this is all
kind of coming out.
Like we were saying
up here, kind
of growing out in
all directions.
This is now where you can see
the cancer, next to the normal.
You know we had talked
before about dysplasia.
This is really bad.
SAL: With a capital B.
DR. CONNOLLY: Yep.
Small children off
the street could
be able to tell you
that this is bad.
SAL: Right.
After they watch this video.
DR. CONNOLLY: Exactly.
And so these are
the normal ones.
They're doing their J-O-B job.
Making the mucin,
nuclei at the bottom.
What is this guy doing?
It's just chaos.
So before we talk
about carcinoma
in situ, a cancer in spot.
If you saw cells this bad, you'd
say do not let them go far.
Because they will have
a tendency to invade.
They're crazy.
So this right here's a
bunch of the cells, that's
a bunch of the cells,
they're these guys here.
You can see they're really
haphazard, they're growing,
they're not doing their--
SAL: So if we found a polyp
that had this stuff that
didn't cross that boundary line
yet, we still would say no,
we've got to take this-- Well
I guess we already took it out.
DR. CONNOLLY: We took it out.
So cancer of the colon
is one of the ones where
surgical cure is
still a classic.
Cut it out, and you're
probably in pretty good shape.
And so there you'd
say, well if it's
the tip of the polyp
that looked like this,
I think we got it out.
But you'd say to yourself,
we better watch this person.
SAL: I see.
So if the whole polyp
kind of looked like that,
you're like, oh let's
cut out a bigger section.
DR. CONNOLLY: Yeah
then you might.
So if it's going
down into the neck,
or getting a little
further, or if you've
cut across it at the
margin, then watch out.
But here's the problem.
Is remember how I said up
here it's not a big deal,
but once you get down near
the veins and arteries?
These guys are running amok
down by the veins, the arteries.
SAL: And so you can actually
see these cells have split off.
And they're infiltrating.
Wow.
DR. CONNOLLY: So you
can see these guys here.
So that's one little
nest of cells.
There's one.
That's probably, right
there, a cancer cell
just dying to get
into that little vein.
SAL: So this is actually, I
can never say the word, meta--
DR. CONNOLLY: Metastasis.
SAL: This is it.
We're seeing it.
DR. CONNOLLY: This is
where it would come from.
SAL: This is where it's
starting to happen.
DR. CONNOLLY: So these
guys are the bad actors.
They're growing in next to
these very fragile little blood
vessels, and so that guy
is knocking on the door.
Once he gets in here, that's a
venule, meaning a little vein.
That's the road out.
SAL: Right.
And it just looks like a
circle here because it's
a two-dimensional
cross-section of it,
but you can imagine it popping
in and out of our screen.
DR. CONNOLLY: Yes.
It would be popping in
and out of our screen.
So this guy would kind of
go in and out of the screen,
connect to this one, and
then it would go out.
SAL: And it's
officially-- I can never
say the word--
metastasized once it's
found a beachhead
someplace else?
DR. CONNOLLY: That's right.
So it's considered
a metastasis where,
let's say, the cell got into the
vessel, if it left the region.
So it went to the
lung, the liver.
This is looking
like you really are
worried that this
could metastasize.
SAL: Right.
DR. CONNOLLY: And so
what's interesting
about this is that when you
look at something like this,
there's such a thing
called, for cancer, grade.
And what grade is,
is basically what we
we've been just talking
about, how bad does that look?
SAL: Right.
DR. CONNOLLY: And so the grade
is, wow, that looks nasty.
I think that--
SAL: Is nasty a technical term?
DR. CONNOLLY: Actually
we use it quite a bit.
Some people say, oh what
did that tumor show?
We say it was nasty.
When we talk about nastiness,
it's a lack of behavior.
If you can get a cell where
the nucleus gets that big,
or sometimes it's that
big, there's chaos.
And there's chaos not
just in nuclear size,
but how it behaves.
SAL: And I guess
the nuclear size
is a telltale, because that
means that the cell is devoting
a lot of its resources
for replication and--
DR. CONNOLLY: It's
for replication,
but it also means, to me, that
normally things in the cellar
are very orderly.
You do not divide your DNA
until these things are already
[INAUDIBLE].
And now it's just
left and right.
So yeah, this would
be a high grade tumor.
And then stage is
the other main thing.
SAL: Yes, I've heard of stage.
DR. CONNOLLY: Stage means,
where is it in the body?
So in this case, if it's these
nasty cells at the very top,
it's actually a lower stage
then if they're nasty cells
and they've come all
the way down here.
SAL: So in situ carcinoma
would still get a stage.
DR. CONNOLLY: It's a stage 0.
SAL: Stage 0.
DR. CONNOLLY: So it's
basically you're nowhere.
And then if you begin to
just cross over, like here,
and invade, then
you're in stage 1.
And then there are depths
as you go for stages.
And then there's
always the other thing,
where did it go off to
other parts of your body.
And that's the
very highest stage.
SAL: And so this
isn't a-- and this
is true of all cancers, when
people about breast cancer,
I've heard it in
that context a lot.
Stage 1, or stage 0 through 4.
So it isn't just the size.
If the cancerous tissue is big,
but if it's in a safe place,
it could still be
stage 1 or stage 0.
DR. CONNOLLY: It is.
What's interesting about staging
is almost the whole world
has agreed to do the
same kind of staging.
And that staging is
what we're calling TNM.
And T has to do with how
big it is, and the one site,
and how much it's
crossed any barriers.
SAL: Right.
But the barrier crossing sounds
like the most important thing.
DR. CONNOLLY: It does.
Although this one here is,
are they in lymph nodes?
SAL: Oh, right.
DR. CONNOLLY: And
the lymph nodes
are nearby structures
where the lymph goes.
And so that's one road out.
And the other one is metastases.
And so yeah, the staging
has to do with all three.
SAL: I see.
And metastases always
happens through
the circulatory system--
Through the blood, the vessels?
Or does it also happen
through the lymph network?
DR. CONNOLLY: And
so it's something
where going through the lymph
nodes, for something like this,
is one of the first steps.
But getting to the
liver and the lung,
it's got to get into the
blood vessels somehow.
The lymphatic in your colon
connects to a local lymph node,
but does not connect through
lymph only to the lung.
SAL: I see.
DR. CONNOLLY: So it must have
gone into the blood somewhere.
So that's the way it looks here.
And then the final thing here,
when looking at this cancer,
is if we go over here, this is
the greatest depth of invasion.
You had asked me about the
body's immune function.
Well if you look here, now
you see how it's kind of loose
and there are all these
little immune cells?
That's what these guys are.
Those are--
SAL: What's the immune cell?
DR. CONNOLLY: These guys here.
See the little round guys?
Those are lymphocytes.
SAL: I see.
I should circle it, actually.
How can you tell the difference
between the lymphocytes
and the cancer cells?
DR. CONNOLLY: That's
because I'm a pathologist.
SAL: That's because you've
had many years of training.
DR. CONNOLLY: No, but they're
the little round ones.
So this one right here
is a classic cell,
which is called a plasma
cell, in which there's
a nucleus here, and all the rest
of this is making antibodies.
SAL: You're not
circling that area?
DR. CONNOLLY: No,
I'm just drawing.
SAL: Oh, OK.
You're just drawing.
DR. CONNOLLY: So
this guy is this one.
I drew him right--
SAL: OK, you're
zooming in on this.
DR. CONNOLLY: Yeah,
zooming in on that.
So yeah, that's a plasma
cell, meaning it's a nucleus--
SAL: I just want to clarify,
what you've circled there,
just because it could be
a little bit confusing,
but we have this big circle
is maybe we [INAUDIBLE].
DR. CONNOLLY: This is why I
should leave it to the pros.
SAL: No, just because
I'm getting confused.
You're not circling that area.
DR. CONNOLLY: No, no,
I'm not doing that.
SAL: You were just showing
what it looks like zoomed in.
DR. CONNOLLY: Right, so
that's a plasma cell.
SAL: That's a plasma cell.
DR. CONNOLLY: That's
making antibodies, probably
against the tumor.
And so that's the immune
response in that spot.
SAL: And how do you know
that's-- That looked very
similar to the
cancerous cells to me.
DR. CONNOLLY: This one's
a little hard to tell.
And if you had a real microscope
you'd turn up the light.
And we'd have a very
specific look to the nucleus.
And then these guys over here
have little pink granules
in them, which is a
type of immune cell.
And so when looking
through here--
SAL: On this depth, which
ones are cancerous here?
DR. CONNOLLY: OK, so now
let me just get over here,
to this one here, and then
come out just a little bit.
Let me go over here.
Is that when looking
at these guys,
these are all inflammation.
The nearest cancer cell
where I could bet the farm
are these guys up here.
SAL: Oh, OK.
See, when you see on this
view it becomes more obvious.
They definitely look different.
DR. CONNOLLY: They
look different.
And so then when you come
out here, you can see,
there's the cancer.
This is the body's reaction
to the cancer right there.
SAL: I see.
DR. CONNOLLY: At
the deepest zone.
And there are therapies
based on trying
to get more of this
immune response.
SAL: That's amazing.
Very cool.